من ضجيج الحروب العالميه ونعرات الماضي
والحاضر السياسي وشق الصف الاوروبي نعم
تقاتلوا فيما بينهم مات الملايين منهم
وانتهى الامر بتوقيع لتحل سياسه التركيز
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سيطرت واذلت
واصبحت سيده العالم ولكن على حساب الغرب
فهم يخضعون لزيادتها تبتزهم تسيطر على
تحركاتهم
القاره العجوز تحاول الخروج من العباءه
الامريكيه لكن دون جدوى لتحل بهم البلوى
فكيف وضعت امريكا اقوى قارات العالم تحت
وصايتها غضب وسخط اوروبي لقد خدعتنا
واشنطن والى هنا وكفى يزداد الصراخ
الاوروبي ومعه تنتشر رائحه الصراع انها
معارك الاصدقاء الاعداء
من هنا كانت البدايه خلال الحرب العالميه
الاولى وفي بدايه الصراع لعبت الولايات
المتحده دور التاجر المرابي عندما طال امد
الحرب وجد البريطانيون والفرنسيون انفسهم
في حاجه الى قروض كبيره اذا ارادوا ان
ينتصروا في هذا الصراع وهناك
ظهر الامريكي مورجن في الصوره حينها تهللت
اساريره من كثره السعاده وسال لعابه بشكل
مفرط طمعا في ابتزاز الاوروبيين ويا له
مؤمن ابتزاز يا ساده ما نحمورجن الحكومتين
البريطانيه والفرنسيه قرضا بقيمه 500
مليون دولار حينها كان ذلك اكبر قرض في
التاريخ كان موجن قويا كفرد ويتمتع بنفوذ
كبير جدا وهذا ما دفع الرجل الذي يقف وراء
محاوله اغتياله الى الاعتقاد بان التخلص
منه قد يوقف الحرب فعلا
للاسف لقد عاش مورجن واستمرت الحرب بفضل
القرود والامدادات الامريكيه للحلفاء بل
انه بخلاف القروض عمل مورجن كوسيط حيث قام
بنفسه بشراء احتياجات الحلفاء من الطعام
والسلاح وارسالها اليهم كل شهر اي انه كان
يمول الحرب ويدخل كوسيط فيا له من رجل
خبيث لعب على الحبلين ويال غباء القاره
الاوروبيه الاكثر تطورا في العالم
الوجود العسكري الامريكي في اوروبا
السيطره الامريكيه على القاره العجوز ليست
اقتصاديه فحسب بل تسللت امريكا الى
مفاصلهم بعده اتفاقيات عسكريه وامنيه
وكذلك اتفاقيات سياسيه مع نوع من التركيع
والخضوع للاوروبيين ولانهم بحاجه لامريكا
وبحاجه للدخول تحت عباءتها
اقوى دوله في العالم في ذلك الوقت سياسيا
وعسكريا اضطروا لان يوقعوا على تلك
الاتفاقيات بل وتسابقوا من اجل توقيعها
ولكنهم النادم اشد الندم بعد ان تاحت
رائحه واشنطن الخفيه من تلك الاتفاقيات
حيث نشرت الولايات المتحده قوات في مختلف
دول اوروبا خصوصا ما تعرف بالجبهه الشرقيه
لحلف النيتو وقد زاد عدد هذه القوات بعد
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وبينما كان عديد
القوات الامريكيه نحو 80 الف جندي قبل
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا يبلغ حاليا
نحو 100 الف مع زياده قوتها بنحو 20 الفا
ردا على الحرب الروسيه واشنطن لا تكتفي
بالوجود العسكري بل وتدفع لتصعيد الحرب في
اوكرانيا كما يقول الالمان لان ذلك يعمل
على احياء النفوذ الامريكي في المنطقه
ففجاه بدات عديد من القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه التي كانت خامله في السابق
بالنشاط لتشد واشنطن حبلها على القاره
العجوز حتى ان امريكا انسحبت تدريجيا من
الشرق الاوسط منذ نهايه حرب العراق رميه
خسائرها وخسائر اوروبيين عرض الحائط
اوروبا تكاد تدمر ذاتها مضحيه بمصالحيه
وهي تنفذ وتتبع سياسات امريكا بكل تفان
لتنفيذ ما ترسمه امريكا من سياسات وخطط
دعونا نعود للتاريخ قليلا بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه خسرت القوه الاوروبيه في
النزاع معظم احتياطاتها من الذهب لمصلحه
الامريكيين هناك استحوذت امريكا على مخزون
الذهب حتى اصبحت تمتلك اكثر من خمسين
بالمئه من الذهب العالمي الابتزاز
الامريكي لم ينتهي هناك حيث عملت واشنطن
على تقديم مساعدات بهدف ربطها بالاقتصاد
الامريكي والدولار الامريكي واجعل كافه
ديون اوروبا لامريكا مرتبطه بالدولار
الامريكي نعم لقد سيطر الامريكان على
القاره العجوز اقتصادي وسياسيا وحتى
عسكريا يا اصدقاء فلما خضعت اوروبا كل هذا
الخضوع الضغط يولد الانفجار
تصريحات اوروبيه شديده اللهجه تجاه واشنطن
اوروبا يجب ان تعتمد على نفسها امريكا
خدعت الاوروبيين الحرب الروسيه انكت
القاره العجوز يجب ان نلتفت لمصالحنا
بعيدا عن مصالح الولايات المتحده هكذا طفح
الكيل بالاوروبيين ليعلنوا انهاء شهر
العسل مع امريكا وتزيد الاستياء الاوروبي
مهلا مهلا مهلا فالشعب الالماني خرج
ليعلنها للعالم حرب اوكرانيا عادت
بالفائده في جانب صناعات العسكريه
الامريكيه ووضعت اوروبا على حافه التدهور
الاقتصادي الحاد لكن يبدو ان الولايات
المتحده تتجاهل كل تصريحات اوروبا وهي
تعلن في منتصف 2022 الناس تعزز وجودها
العسكري في ست دول اوروبيه وهي بولندا
ورومانيا واسبانيا وايطاليا وبريطانيا
والمانيا بالاضافه الى منطقه البلطيق
لتعزيز الامن في بحر البلطيق كما ترى
واشنطن ليشدد الامريكيون الخناقه على
الاوروبيين وذلك كله لاجبار اوروبا على ان
تتجنب الدخول في منطقه كتله الحلف الروسي
الصيني المتنامي بسرعه الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل يخطط ويحلم بجيش اوروبي موحد لترك
الوصايه الامريكيه على القاره العجوز ذهب
مكون الى الصين واعلن من هناك نعل اوروبا
تقليل اعتمادها على امريكا رئيس مكون لم
يكتفي بذلك بل نضاف بان اوروبا قد زادت من
اعتمادها على امريكا في مجال الاسلحه
والطاقه ويتوجب التركيز على تعزيز
الصناعات الدفاعيه الاوروبيه زادت واشنطن
من الضغط على اوروبا فصعد قاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي اللجه ضد النزعه الحمائيه في
الولايات المتحده
بتوفير دعم استثنائي للشركات المنتجه على
اراضيها وهو ما يتعرض تماما مع قواعد
التجاره العالميه بحسب الاوروبيين وبينما
تدعم امريكا الشركات التي في اراضيها
تزداد الخسائر في شركات القاره العجوز
لانفجر غضب الاوروبيين العارم وتضج
الشوارع بالمحتجين مطالبين حكوماتهم
بالابتعاد عن الولايات المتحده لكن هل
تتركهم الولايات المتحده وشانهم لا يبدو
ذلك ممكنا وبعد كل هذه الانتقادات
الاوروبيه الطويله لوح مسؤولون اوروبيون
باللجوء الى تدابير قضائيه لكن وكما
يقولها اليمنيون اذا كان خصمك القاضي ثم
انتقاضي لتكشف وثائق امريكيه مسربه ان
النفوذ الولايات المتحده في عدد من الدول
يتراجع وذلك لتجنب الدول الانحياز لامريكا
في مو اجهتها مع الصين وروسيا وفق موقع
اكسيوس بل ان قاده اوروبا يسعون لانهاء
القيود الكاسحه المفروضه من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه على الصين
الشرخ الاوروبي يتسع لم تنسى القوه العظمى
الاولى في العالم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولم تغفر للهوروبيين يوما
محاولاتهم خلال السنوات الاخيره التقرب من
روسيا والاعتماد على نفطها وغازها وربطهم
بها بخطوط غاز عملاقه كخطي نورديستريم بل
كانت تحثهم دائما على الاعتماد على الغاز
والنفط الامريكي كبديل للروسي فزعت اليوم
الى استغلال الحرب لتضييق الخناق على
الاوروبيين وابتزازهم بهدف قطع علاقتهم مع
روسيا واعادتهم للحظيره الامريكيه وحققت
اهدافها في الفتره الماضيه لكن ليس بعد
اليوم يا ساده منذ اندلاع الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه والقوه الغربيه المتمثله في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الاوروبيه جزء اصيل من تلك الحرب
باعتبارها من اكثر
المساندين والداعمين لاوكرانيا في تلك
الازمه ولكن بعد قرب مرور عام على بدء تلك
الحرب بدا جليا ان الولايات المتحده هي
اكبر الرابحين واوكرانيا والدول الاوروبيه
اكثر المتضررين منها حتى الان فهل بدا
الشرخ الغربي بالتصدع وهل يقفز الاوروبيون
من المركب الامريكي المتهالي
[موسيقى]